all right this is the try not to laugh
unboxing challenge here's how this is
gonna work we're gonna take turns
recording an unboxing video all we have
to do is open the box and talk about the
item inside for one way but the catch is
we have no idea what's in the box is
being given to us we each chose three
boxes for each other the only rule
no laughing at all this is gonna be
impossible so you can't laugh while
unboxing or while watching the other
person each laugh is a point for the
other person person with the most points
at the end of three rounds wins I'm
gonna win I'm gonna crush you okay okay
chill out okay who goes first
rock-paper-scissors they'll sue it it's
the most far away right there how do you
count is it Ron Paper Scissors shoot
yeah okay ready Rock Paper Scissors
shoot Rock Paper Scissors shoot
oh I wasn't thinking you weren't
thinking I just went in well that's a
rock brother
oh hi unbox first you unbox first okay
so the moment I get the box
no laughing he's getting it from behind
the blue seamless
what's up took out
oh god I'm already messing this up
what's up to blockers and taboc Aeons
welcome to debauch tuesdays today we're
gonna be doing some unboxing videos I
have been waiting for this package let's
check it out okay so it comes in nice
like there it's it's a pretty empty box
right not not fancy or anything but
that's okay if the products good enough
and it comes with two an envelope and I
don't even know what this is it's easy
makeup which is what my youtube channel
is you know it's a I make a makeup
channel and it's me and James Charles
out here competing and so make sure not
to watch named Charles cuz I'm Way
better than James Charles so you have
basically these Wow
glasses that I think flip flip so like
if you have one one bad eye you just
kind of you you don't you know you can
see out of this eye but this is a bad
eye so you just flip it and then you
have a little card that you can now read
which you wouldnt be able to read before
it's a great card
nice and flexible made out of real paper
I think and wow it's I don't know if my
glasses are 3d or if the let me see yes
this thing is actually 3d and it's a
birthday birthday card great product I
love this you should get the glasses I
did it okay one minute Wow I was
impressive I think I'm blind in one of
the eyes now what is this this packaging
almost made me laugh wait and a birthday
card yeah oh this was the only card I
could find sincerely Chris okay do you
like it I love it great would it go on
my personal channel probably not that's
fair
and we're off hey everybody welcome back
I've been really really excited about
this product so as we open here just as
expected and I knew this Oh excellent
all right I don't you know as you order
things like this rules typically you're
not supposed to touch it touch it but it
isn't unboxing I'll go ahead and hold
that up it is alarmingly damp pair of
Calvin Klein underwear it does appear to
be soiled which I did request I did ask
for that so it's really nice to see when
whoever you purchase the underwear from
delivers on their promise that they will
be soiled they will be damned I honestly
don't even know if this is actually I'm
almost like out of unboxing
holy God whoa no I know but so oh my god
whoa I almost gagged like three times
listen listen okay
in the BuzzFeed bathroom I put Nutella
all over it and I felt like I put way
too much Nutella so I tried to wash some
of it off and I literally felt like I
was washing underwear that was soiled
that was wow wow wow wow
watching you oh my god well thank you
welcome these are great I mean seriously
whew wash them you can totally wear them
after
just think about how much you hated high
school and how Chris is mean to you in
the office oh my god this one's like
really taped up we got a really fragile
package today let's just pull it one by
one
oh boy okay oh okay okay
all right unboxing time ooh oh it's very
fragile we got some bubble wrap I love
bubble wrap you just got a bubble it a
little bit mm mm honestly just bubble
wrap would have been a good package if
anyone wants to send me a bunch of
bubble wrap I'm down for that
okay oh my god
yes yes yes yes you guys know me so well
like honestly I know I have a whole
sandwich show and I just my whole
channel is just me eating sandwiches but
and how did you guys know tuna and and
and I could find out what incredible
fans sent this to me because they took a
bite okay so I'm gonna take their DNA
I'm gonna go get a little DNA swab I'm
gonna find out who send this to me I'm
gonna come over to your house I know who
you are I'm gonna find you and I'm gonna
I'm gonna kiss you right on the mouth
and I'm gonna be like thank you man with
my tuna breath is this tuner is this
chicken oh okay mm-hmm mmm let's taste
it Oh a little dangerous a little
dangerous there is this sandwich does
come with a little toothpick right there
on the edge okay I'm kind of scared to
eat it cuz and should I take a bite only
if you want to
mmm fire right now yeah that was good it
was good I felt confident that one I was
like listen I'm not laughing
but that was funny did you take this
bite I don't know it's a big box all
right what's up to Bacher's I knew you
were expecting Eric on this channel but
uh you know the fans travel really
really excited for this absolutely so
what we have here is the picture frame
that I ordered that is me I knew I knew
I wanted a really tasteful print so what
I went with was a picture of myself on
vacation
where I am naked on a balcony um
drinking vodka my wife took this photo
there are lots of people on that beach
and I thought I just wanted something to
warm my cold dark home up and what
better way to do that than a naked
picture of yourself on vacation and I
thought that would really be a great
treat and it came out the print came out
really really nice the colors are great
I had heard nothing but good things from
this printing company and its really I'm
really impressed with the work and I
will absolutely order more naked photos
of myself from the supplier it's really
special and outside look a little ripped
in this photo like a little cut those
days are long gone
you're good you know why I laughed
because I think you didn't know what it
was and then the way you just casually
was like it is of me really really
killed me for that why is that on
Instagram it's a great picture based
like and thank you for this gift yeah of
course it's really nice isn't it it is
nice
alright guys this is Chris Guerra
and this is my last video ever see
what's inside that was my first ever
review was a picture frame and I just
love I love pictures and when they're in
frames they just look so much nicer see
what what the company sent me this time
[Music]
come on everything you catch up okay oh
this is this is my best friend Erik
taboc this is Chris Guerra and Chris
Guerra that's me on a bicycle on a tree
on a tree three bicycle I don't know
what you call them but we are great
friends and no no if I didn't laugh when
you laugh I was so good until you
laughed every time I heard you laughing
I felt so accomplished that you laughs
that I laugh a real back and forth a
frame-off when did you photoshop this
today hmm
to me it almost looks like I'm
transforming into you like an animal
like a tandem bicycle yeah yeah yeah
appreciate you coming back to my youtube
channel we have our final unboxing of
the day excellent excellent excellent
yeah for sure
so as expected we have two envelopes
here one says don't open and the other
says top secret now I knew this was
gonna happen because I ordered these
things and I think what we do first if
my memory serves me correct in the
directions online it's to open the don't
open one so I I think I remember what is
in this one and I'll if memory serves me
correct absolutely it says don't again
let's put a pin in this one because now
I'm starting to think that top steer kid
was was actually uh is actually the way
to go let's go ahead and open top-secret
absolutely what we have here folks is
some Remo belong terror excellent and as
you know this is top secret this is
secret hair wrap wait but open the other
one yeah i'll open the other one wait
okay what happens if you open the other
one what happened will account
uh-oh if i laugh will count it let's see
okay so we'll punch back in who punch
back in on the word punch punching back
into the video we ran out of time but
we're gonna make an exception here Eric
possibly with a with a buzzer-beater
moment don't don't
open alright and then what we have here
it's right it says don't open what we
have is a bald picture of the President
of the United States this is really
special I think these are both
top-secret that's why I ordered them I
love both of these and very much do you
get the connection is this his hair it's
his hair I lost no know that I
this is that the count I should have
just should have just had three boxes
all filled with wet underwear you know
what fine fair and square you won I lost
so this is everything I got today for
the unboxing experiment and and this is
everything I got I love it I hope you
like yours and I do like mine uh some
more than others I will say I do like
some of these more than others
seriously though thank you you're
welcome have a good way